when you think of breath of the wild you
probably know it as that really popular
open world zelda game that everyone
compares everything to
but you might also know it for another
reason glitches
over the years this one's wholesome game
has been slowly broken and brought down
to its knees by glitch hunters to the
point where duplicating weapons
breaking reality getting impossible
weapons insta-killing bosses
clipping through walls and launching
across the map has become commonplace in
hyrule
as a precursor let's note that we will
be covering the most famous and useful
glitches
we're crediting my first video proof and
these are just basic explanations of
these 19 historic breakthroughs that
made this list of glitch of the wild
if you enjoy content like this let us
know by hitting that subscribe button
as the community and i put a lot of work
to make this happen for you with that
said
let's take a time machine back to breath
of the wild's humble beginnings
[Music]
back in the early days of breath of the
wild speedrunning this first major trick
allowed link to be quickly moving at all
times
by holding down the whistle button and
mashing sprint he would not only not use
stamina but recover it as well
and easily scale steep hills there were
whispers that whistle sprinting was
possible on the day of the game's
release
with the first video footage being
posted the very next day this as well as
a less consistent but quieter throw
sprinting which was also discovered on
the game's release day are still used to
this day
in both speed running and casual play
[Music]
believe it or not this technique was
found literally two days after the
game's launch
but the potential wasn't completely
understood until it resurfaced nearly a
year and a half later
shield clipping completely changed the
game with its flexibility and ease of
use
by bonking your shield on an angled
surface length position is saved at that
angle and he will pivot harshly back
when he unequips his shield again
doing this shield bunk during bullet
time also led to the discovery of skew
bouncing which made aggressive skews
that launch link upwards for easy bullet
time in combat
this concept led to many massive speed
running discoveries including skipping
all sorts of shrines and skipping trial
of the sword entirely and has been in
use ever since
the base idea for stasis launching was
technically performed as early as july
9th
2016 in a breath of the wild demo before
the game's launch
but it officially made its way into
mainstream speedrunning within the first
several days of breath of the wild's
launch
by spin attacking a stasis object then
grabbing it or hitting yourself with it
mid-air
this launched link at high speeds while
people argue that it is just physics
manipulation and not actually a glitch
what matters is it paved the way for a
multitude of general launching
techniques that would evolve over the
years
this advanced technique was found
literally one week after the release of
breath of the wild but was also written
off as something useful in speed runs
because it needed the hylian shield
over a year later user yuda repurposed
it for something else entirely
combat by hitting your shield while
jumping without breaking it it would
knock you upwards and allow a second
jump
giving you enough height for bullet time
it's amazing to see a move that was
initially ignored become one of the most
useful combat techniques ever created
one of the first major speed running
techniques to get you off the great
plateau tower
this allowed you to fall from any height
without the paraglider and not
die upon impact by throwing and
switching equipment at the last second
before you hit the ground you negate
fall damage entirely
while this becomes unnecessary once you
get the paraglider this is still
to this day invaluable when combined
with modern launch techniques to
speedrun safely on the great plateau
before you get the paraglider shortly
after the discovery of stasis launching
people started randomly getting launches
with double the speed and distance
not knowing why this launch seems really
fast
like look at this how's this launched so
fast
it was nearly two weeks later that
players started to grasp why these super
launches were occurring and it was
because opening the paraglider while the
game is dropping frame late from loading
multiple objects on screen
caused link to massively increase its
momentum this was researched further and
players developed ways to forcefully
induce this lag to make super speed
launches a consistent speed run
technique
to this day it's still used in
conjunction with many launching
techniques to massively increase
launching capabilities
while the flying machine was fairly
useful for traversing the map without
using any resources
people fondly remember this glitch more
for the sheer spectacle of flying across
a map in this ridiculous contraption
by placing a metal box or minecart on
top of another minecart magnesium seeing
the lower cart will lift the cart
between you and link and levitate link
upwards infinitely it's hard to forget
it once you've seen it
[Music]
one of the most popular glitches to this
day because of its high utility
menu overloading has gone through
several iterations over the years
to a streamlined setup that now takes
about 10 seconds to perform
by having multiple active multi-shot
shock bows in a certain area the game's
memory overloads allowing the player to
desync inventory items in beneficial
ways
the ability to duplicate and transfer
durability of equipment
and take advantage of a certain npc to
perform the best groupie farming method
in the game
has made this one of the most valuable
glitches in breath of the wild history
there weren't many huge combat
discoveries in the game's first year but
one of the bigger exploits at the time
was the bow spin
by pressing attack and bow shot while
spinning a heavy weapon it would place
the active weapon on your back put the
bow in your hands
it was initially passed off as a gimmick
until i found its secret combat effects
with great frostblades and great
thunderblades to perform ice and thunder
chaining
shortly after i discovered true freeze
chaining which is still the only
technique in the game that keeps the
enemy locked in a frozen state
completely never breaking them out of
frozen status while getting hit
arguably the most iconic combat trick to
this day the rook's perfect parry allows
a user to use the roof's protection
infinitely
over and over but in order to initiate
this trick you must release cl within
two frames of the attack or bomb
striking link
making this move not just efficient for
combat but also a show of high skill to
perform this timing specific trick
this technique's versatility got only
more and more advanced as time went on
with the addition of perfect to root
crushes
quick crushes rook's launch
and landing the roof rushes
there were small breakthroughs in
launching techniques in breath of the
wild at this point
but none is game changing in terms of
speed and distance as bullet time
bounces
while it was initially shown off as
early as august 2018 it didn't find an
audience until another user posted it to
twitter and went viral
by striking an enemy with their shield
to make them ragdoll while you're in
bullet time
link was propelled at unreal speeds with
capabilities even surpassing super
launches
setups improved as time went on and this
became one of the most common ways to
navigate the world during speed runs
by performing a sequence involving a
glitched camera state holding an item
and viewing a memory the game then leads
to unique effects loading into different
areas
shrine apparatus storage led to several
important findings including
exploring a bottom of void pits keeping
death mountain's hot air effects around
you which led to explosive combat
techniques
ignoring all elements and most useful of
all the ability to steal the master
sword early and duplicate hearts and
stamina
perfect for the completionists who
wanted a full row of hearts and stamina
another version of this iconic glitch
was technically seen as early as four
months after the game's release with the
finding of the world reset glitch
but was quickly patched it then
resurfaced years later when a player
wanted to take pictures with the
guardian and then accidentally refound
the glitch by pushing it to strange
places
breath of the wild's map is broken up
into a grid system and by pushing a
dynamic object
two grid spaces over the guardian would
then spawn endless guardian parts
this led to the best way to farm ancient
materials in the game
[Music]
moon jumping brought both entertainment
and speed running value giving players
freedom to jump to any height and go
anywhere they please
mounting a wild horse while you owned a
horse during the mounted archery
minigame caused link to be stuck in this
moon jump state
this shortly after brought the discovery
of wrong warping to breath of the wild
allowing link to spawn in certain
predetermined locations including brand
new areas he's never explored before
as well as out of bounds
out of all the discoveries in breath of
the wild wind bombs also known as bomb
impact launches
is arguably one of the most important
ever found by placing two bombs in a row
behind link in bullet time
the wind box of the farthest bomb pushed
the closer bomb into link and launched
them at high speeds
this new foundability completely strong
armed every obstacle breath of the wild
built
for puzzling and exploration and tossed
it to the side giving the ability to
completely skip shrines and traverse the
world in a multitude of custom angles
speeds and directions this technique to
traverse massive distances in any
direction at any time
with very little setup changed breath of
the wild forever
[Music]
ways to insta kill bosses have always
been sought after for glitch hunters and
on november 9th 2019
the exploit to completely skip wind
blight or calamity ganon were
found by firing an arrow before entering
an introduction cutscene the invisible
suspended arrow did live continuous
damage through the cutscene
making the boss dead on arrival breath
of the wild speed running was never the
same ever since
the introduction of the thunderclap rush
completely opened up a new layer of
combat to the game
by pressing attack and bow shot while in
midair this would force the game to
initiate bullet time and flurry rushes
back to back
this led to a much deeper understanding
of the market chase mechanic which is
the backbone of how the game figures out
where to put link while he's flurry
rushing
if there's anything we've seen so far
that screams glitch this would take the
cake
this strange bug is exclusive to the
switch version of breath of the wild and
was initially found as a lizalfos curse
but for some reason it was patched out
when the vr update was added to breath
of the wild
this glitch was seemingly lost forever
until it was re-found through the henox
curse and the boomerang curse
by bringing a he knocks or style knocks
to a waterfall or throwing a boomerang
underwater while the game was overloaded
the entire game engine breaks causing
the rotation bug and some of the
creepiest physics glitches possible in
breath of the wild
finally what many have considered as the
most difficult complex and most
rewarding glitch in recent discovery is
the memory storage glitch
by performing a complex frame perfect
menu glitch this allows link to play a
brand new file while you have a memory
stored
by then completing the new game without
ever dying because the game will not
save
this allows link to duplicate colosseum
enemies obtain the unobtainable bow of
light
skip the great plateau obtain 80 000
arrows and more
this is in a sense the uncovering of a
true new game plus file
and by far is one of the most colossal
discoveries ever found in breath of the
wild
[Music]
and that brings us to today this game
has been completely transformed
over the past four years and although
this may seem like quite a few
discoveries
the actual list of glitches easily goes
into the thousands and will continue to
climb as people keep pushing breath of
the wild
a big thank you to the breath of the
wild community for helping develop this
list and if you enjoyed this journey
back in time
subscribe to gamespot to keep up with
the latest breath of the wild content
[Music]
you